[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno a tutti
il il vento è il tema il tema importante
della giornata in particolare
il cambio del vento a siamo già scusati
guardo quando
il cambio del vento ha caratterizzato un
po mi occupo di innovazione ha iniziato
sulla rete nel 94 quindi quando è nata
sostanzialmente la rete commerciale
il vento è cambiato tantissimo
appoggiandoci oggi alla metafora del
vento del mare sicuramente abbiamo avuto
molte libecciate molto scirocco qualche
bonaccia anche un buon maestrale che ha
spinto le cose sicuramente
per arrivare
oggi faremo un excursus di questi 25
anni di rete anche per capire cosa ci
aspetta
appunto il cambio del vento
ci ha portato
inizialmente stiamo parlando del 95 2000
ad avere
questa è una specie di terreno di
coltura il piatto di petri in cui invece
delle cellule appunto gli atomi hanno
iniziato a comporre un mondo nuovo mondo
nuovo che sta avvolgendo tutto il globo
e che sta ponendo anche dei problemi
perché
è un mondo che ha delle regole
completamente diverse
e che deve essere interpretata a livello
di cultura digitale è talmente veloce la
cultura coltura degli atomi
che stanno portando proprio il mondo a
trasformarsi che sta generando un
programma molto grande che quello del
digital divide cioè del divario digitale
che abbiamo fra un mondo che grazie alla
spinta del vento ma sempre più
rapidamente in accelerazione 25 anni
sembrano preistoria ma in realtà sono
avvenute tantissime cose sia ricordare
come come era la rete del 94 e
all'interno di questo terreno di coltura
ovviamente bisogna cercare di lavorare
intorno alla cultura di alla cultura
digitale
per me tutto è iniziato nel 95 quando ho
creato la mia prima società e questo è
il 2000 e 2000 esattamente l'anno in cui
dopo i primi cinque anni di bootstrap
della società in cui con grande fatica
abbiamo iniziato a lavorare su un
pubblico indirizzabile molto basso
perché chiaramente la navigazione in
rete era piuttosto scarse ricordate tra
il 95 2000
questo è il momento della hit you è
questo che vedete è come cattelan
diciamo saluta la borsa con la sua opera
libertà o di vendetta eternità
in realtà il dito è quella una mano con
le dita mozzate in realtà diciamo si può
interpretare in vari modi
perché la borsa chiaramente è una cosa
che divide puoi essere una società
privata può essere una città pubblica
quando diventi una società pubblica
quotata a e delle tematiche di
di avere un numero di azionisti molto
elevati ad esempio questa cosa l'ho
affrontata intorno ai 30 anni per me è
stata la libertà di far partecipare il
mio progetto molte persone e azionisti
erano 27 mila al momento nel 2000 e la
libertà di avere anche i capitani
necessarie per poter far crescere e
quindi partecipare a quel diciamo piatto
di petri in cui la la cultura diciamo
degli atomi
della rete internet come la vediamo oggi
mi ha visto partecipare
cerchiamo di creare un futuro un futuro
che è sempre più difficile da immaginare
ci sono parole chiave che hanno
caratterizzato
quasi a livello trimestrale
la crescita della rete
un po come quando ci fu il web 2.0 che
iniziò a interpretare tutta una serie di
servizi e cercare e di metterli insieme
siamo passati dalla rete strutturata da
website
servizi alle imprese
i primi servizi di chat primi servizi di
di pagine web per personali e siamo
arrivati poi a metterla insieme a far
interagire i servizi tra loro a
colloquiare e quindi a passare da una
rete che era semplicemente una rete di
lettura a una rete di scrittura quella
che oggi ci fa partecipare quando noi
postiamo in quel momento siamo diventati
degli scrittori prima erano solo nei
lettori considerata che nel 95 96 97
sostanzialmente la rete era solo
sfogliabile o poco di più poteri
diciamo scrivere in rete pochissime cose
è il solo in su pochissimi siti
c'è una cosa importante da notare
che nel mercato particolarmente
difficile pieno di squali e il mercato
del futuro in qualche modo
ci deve spingere a non sembrare una foca
nella metafora
della foca ci sta il il surfista che
tipicamente quando la scuola è a 15
metri sott'acqua guarda verso l'alto
vede una forma in questo caso il
surfista lo scambia per una foca va su
loro zanna sperando che vada bene per
non prenderla tavola prendo una gamba ma
purtroppo
queste cose accadono e pensava fosse una
foca
in questo mercato così complesso dove ci
sono degli squali dominanti cioè in
questo in questi 25 anni si sono create
delle posizioni dominanti ci sono verità
molto grandi e nessuno è al riparo
quello che si può fare in questo caso è
di cercare di non assomigliare a una
foca cercare di fare in modo in pratica
che l'attività digitale o attività in
trasformazione digitale che stiamo
facendo
assomigli il meno possibile a una foca
per essere in qualche modo poco
interessante per gli squali del mercato
è un discorso un po complesso
lo capisco perché
però riguarda effettivamente tutti a
tutti i livelli riguarda sia le imprese
mature perché vanno incontro a una
trasformazione e vanno incontro a
società globali molto grandi che
vanno a prendersi il mercato veramente
come si immaginava globalizzazione un
tempo in qualche modo era avvenuta e la
rete è partecipe di questa cosa ma anche
i nostri giovani quando dopo il percorso
di studi devono iniziare a pensare dove
posizionarsi ecco posizioniamoci in
un'attività che non sia in cui non
stanno andando le società dominanti
perché molto probabilmente
andranno a levarci mercato a renderci la
vita impossibile possiamo invece in
qualche modo lavorare sulle loro
piattaforme o possiamo lavorare in
posizioni posizionamenti che siano
sostenibili
per un futuro
negli ultimi 25 anni
ridendo ci sono stati tantissimi trend e
ogni ogni mese praticamente c'era una
parola
diciamo una parola ad effetto che andava
a a definire quale sarebbero state le
direzioni
sono stato piuttosto fortunato le cose
sono sono andate bene nel senso che
alcune società che ho creato poi sono
state vendute le cosiddette exit
le dinamiche di ex.it generano poi delle
altre società quindi è
bisogna pensare che fai crescere una
società può essere che interessi un
altro player la vendi coni di solito con
i proventi di questa vendita
vai a generare altre società il mercato
delle startup quello di cui vi sto
parlando è un pò al mercato di cui mi
occupo funziona così che funziona così
un po il futuro perché
le cambiamenti tecnologici sono tali e
tanti che spesso e volentieri ci
dobbiamo
reinventare se non seguire in maniera
molto molto attenta l'evoluzione è fare
quasi un
un'insegnante ci dobbiamo imparare
continuamente non possiamo smettere di
studiare ma dobbiamo continuare a
studiare per tutta la vita
la domanda
diciamo a cui non ho una risposta
evidentemente quindi vi anticipo già
alla fine del talk è quale sarà la
prossima la prossima cosa è rilevante
ricordate gli anni novanta qualcuno di
voi ricorderà si parlava di
impacchettava tutto all'interno del tema
delle autostrade dell'informazione
quindi tu prendevi tutte le cose
interattive i servizi internet provider
i servizi di rete così via di chéri ecco
queste sono
lato strada le informazioni a questo è
il futuro poi arrivato web 2.0 che ha di
nuovo messo tutti i servizi che erano
nati dopo il 2000
e il raton etichetta euro questa
etichetta che si chiama quando web 2.0
che sono un po i servizi che usiamo oggi
e sono quelli che usiamo sullo
smartphone dal 2007 in poi ma prima
ancora sulla rete sono servizi tutti
connessi in cui ogni servizio parla con
l'altro e si è venuta a creare
la rete come la conosciamo oggi ma come
sarà la rete che viene dopo
il metaverso il metaverso è la metafora
attraverso la quale riprendendo
diciamo determini di fantascienza si sta
immaginando cosa verrà dopo
il vento del metaverso è un po quello
che ci interessa oggi capirne la
direzione
anche in questo caso
non è una cosa specifica ma è un insieme
di tecnologie
alcune delle quali sopravviveranno altre
non sopravviveranno scompariranno però
sicuramente l'aggregazione di alcune di
queste genereranno
la rete come la vediamo
considerata che il mercato degli
smartphone è praticamente in saturazione
quindi le tecnologie se vedete le ultime
uscite ormai
compì evoluti assomigliano sempre di più
cioè si sta migliorando la parte
fotografica insomma è difficile
immaginare che lo smartphone possa
essere l'ultima frontiera
bisogna immaginare cosa viene dopo
quindi
probabilmente
consideriamo il metaverso come un
insieme di tecnologie dalla crittografia
cioè il mondo della block chain
mondo delle cripto il mondo degli
affetti di cui parleremo a breve
e il mondo delle virtual reality
non ci siamo mai che non sia mai
propriamente affermato il mondo
dell'aumento di reality che ha
probabilmente che ha più a che fare con
la sovrapposizione del reale del
virtuale nella vita di tutti i giorni
questo è un tema sicuramente che ha una
possibilità di successo superiore a
quello della virtù rette che più
immersiva che quella per capirsi con con
gli occhiali in cui ti immergi in una
realtà una realtà parallela in questo
caso di mf ti fanno parte del discorso
della della crittografia della block
chain in particolare tiri sono dei non
funge ball top cioè sono sostanzialmente
dei token dei dei gettoni diciamo e non
solo fungibili cioè non sono un dollaro
contro un dollaro mbit con contro i
bitcoin sono scambiabili ma sono
specifici quest'opera che si chiama
pesce tanica che era fatta per stata
fatta da federico clapis
lasciando in mezzo al mare un pesce una
tanica a forma di pesce con un diciamo
un gps per essere ritrovato viene
lasciata in mezzo al mare poi lui va con
una barca a vela a ricercarla la trova e
diventa un'opera è diventata anche un
opera virtuale e quindi in esiste la
copia materiale e la copia virtuale in
un'unica in un'unica copia appunto in mf
tv che il token agganciato a questa
block chain che è un grande libro unico
immaginato un grande libro universale
distribuito unico
in cui possiamo notare le cose e nessuno
lo possiede ed è centralizzato ed è
questo un po anche nel metaverso la
possibilità che le nostre identità non
siano più centralizzate sulle grandi
compagnie che conosciamo ma che siano
sempre più decentralizzate e quindi in
qualche modo ne potremmo diventare
maggiormente proprietari
la virtual reality
l'avete sempre lista ma in realtà quante
volte l'avete vista veramente
funzionante diffusa direi scarsamente la
mente id reality
ricordate il google glasses poi non le
avete più visti
adesso si incomincia rivedere qualcosa
si incomincia a vedere
come gli smartphone hanno la possibilità
insomma di
posizionarsi bene nello spazio grazie
alla sensoristica ultima
probabilmente una maggiore possibilità
di successo
il
però il punto interrogativo è proprio
questo il punto interrogativo proprio
quale di queste tecnologie in parallelo
andranno a creare un nuovo mondo
il dopo quello che viene dopo i social
media quello che avviene dopo gli
smartphone ed ha molto immaginato come
prova pro a darvi un immagine noi
pensavamo al teletrasporto un tempo
pensavamo di poter prendere il nostro
corpo è spostato in un altro luogo in
realtà il teletrasporto noi non ci
rendiamo conto ma in qualche modo è
avvenuto
ovviamente non siamo noi che ci
spostiamo ma il luogo che viene da noi
quindi ad esempio quando faccio una v
aree immersiva faccio un esempio fidenza
15 milioni di turisti l'anno
su 7 miliardi e mezzo di abitanti
anche nei prossimi 100 anni
tantissimi non la vedranno probabilmente
la potranno vedere così
quindi in realtà non siete le
trasportano a firenze da
dal pakistan ma in realtà vivranno
un'esperienza molto simile a essere a
firenze con la virtù si va sofisti qando
viene immaginato quindi il metaverso
come un mondo in cui
andiamo sempre in maniera più immersiva
dentro
inoltre smartphone o quelle che saranno
le attrezzature che ci forniranno in
futuro un po come i nostri figli fanno
giornalmente con i videogames che sono
sempre più realistici e sono sempre più
all'interno
diciamo di un ambiente di un ambiente e
mercy va
la cosa l'ha con l'unica cosa che ci
insegna veramente la storia è che
qualcosa dovrà pur accadere
e l'appuntamento col futuro è sempre più
incerto e complesso
la mia raccomandazione su questo che è
un po torniamo al tema diciamo il
problema generato
dalla rete la rete ce n'erano tantissime
opportunità ma ha aperto un grandissimo
problema che è quello di questo divario
culturale
come raccomandazione appunto di non
smettere mai di imparare
il digitale in ciascuna area in cui
opero iate perché questo è sicuramente
un mondo
trasversale che sta cambiando le regole
del gioco e si rischia se non siamo
abbastanza attenti di rimanerne fuori
la rete nata per equalizzare
democratizzare si rischia se non andiamo
culturalmente nella stessa direzione di
subire la rete
anziché trarne vantaggio grazie a tutti
[Applauso]